hey guys my name is Jess today it is May
12 and this is your Thursday edition of
game Spartan much as part of its latest
earnings report Ubisoft has announced
that the division has 9.5 million
registered users and Far Cry primal has
been doing pretty well for itself to UV
said active players are spending an
average of three hours a day in the
division they added that February's Far
Cry primal exceeded expectations and had
the best performance ever for a game
released in the month of februari on top
of that rainbow 6 siege apparently
doubled its audience during the year and
the publisher posted a fourth-quarter
revenue figure of 620 4.9 million euros
an in-depth report by Eurogamer has
explored both the recently devolved
lionhead studios and what fables walk
the fence lion heads John McCormick said
he wanted the game to run on Unreal
Engine 4 and to push the series into the
technological industrial age with tram
cars and flying machines he added we
wanted to hit the late Victorian proper
far out Jules Verne [ __ ] fable Thor's
main city would have been massive and
dense featuring characters including
Jack the Ripper and the plan was to make
the game much darker and grittier
unfortunately that pitch was rejected by
microsoft in favor of the free to play
fable legends McCormick cites the
rejection as one of the reasons he quit
lyin head in 2012 having asked Microsoft
for the development time and money that
are given to games like mass effect and
Skyrim and being turned down finally
woodstocks who will have a different
time to that of the first game jiri
sub-ceo EBEs Guillermo said that watch
dogs too will have a new tone and
innovative gameplay which does indeed
basically tell us nothing but that's
what we have to work off for now he
added that the game has the potential to
be one of ubisoft's best-selling games
of all time which again doesn't say a
lot the first to watch dogs game sold
nine million copies into retail and
earlier this month and in
photo surfaced which may have featured
the main character of which dogs too I
mean they're down in that comment
section what you want to see from watch
dogs to and be sure to head to
GameSpot's where we've got stories on
Gran Turismo and love some of their
generation that is everything I have for
you today but you come back tomorrow for
the five biggest stories of the entire
week I will catch you been